[THE EUROPEAN BATTERY ALLIANCE]
[TURNS 5 THIS YEAR]
[STILL TAKING BABY STEPS]
[OR GROWING UP FASTER
THAN EXPECTED?]
We have seen far more
than baby steps.
Five years ago, the EU battery industry
was hardly on the map.
Today, Europe is a global battery hotspot
with 127 billion euros in investment
and some 111 industrial projects
emerging across our Member States.
And we keep moving forward.
[WHAT OBJECTIVE]
[IS DRIVING YOU FORWARD?]
To see Europe among
the global leaders in e-mobility,
an essential part of the green
and digital economy.
We are well on track
to produce enough batteries
for 11 million cars a year
by 2030.
If we can maintain this momentum,
I am sure we will achieve
strategic autonomy
in the battery sector.
[HOW CAN YOU KEEP]
[YOUR MOMENTUM GOING]
[IN 2022?]
First, it is high time
to adopt the proposed
batteries regulation,
setting high
sustainability requirements
for batteries placed
onto the EU market.
Second, we all have to put our backs
into securing battery raw materials.
And third,
I want to see
our European Battery Academy
expanding across
more Member States,
to prepare our workforce
for this fast-growing sector.
So stay tuned!